[Música]
en la historia bíblica de la torre de
Babel la humanidad hablaba un solo
idioma hasta que se dividieron en varios
grupos incapaces de entenderse entre
ellos
no sabemos si ese idioma original
existió pero sí sabemos que los miles de
idiomas actuales pueden rastrearse hasta
un número mucho menor Cómo hemos acabado
con tantos en la época histórica de las
migraciones el mundo estaba mucho menos
poblado los grupos de personas que
compartían idioma y cultura solían
dividirse en tribus más pequeñas
buscando casa fresca y tierras fértiles
conforme mi graban y se asentaban en
otros sitios quedaban aislados entre
ellos y evolucionaron de formas
distintas tras siglos de vida diferente
con otra comida y con vecinos distintos
los dialectos parecidos con variaciones
en pronunciación y vocabulario se
convirtieron en idiomas distintos que se
dividieron a medida que los pueblos
crecían y se expandían más
como los genealogistas los lingüistas
intentan crear un mapa de este proceso
rastreando varios idiomas tan atrás como
es posible hasta su antepasado común o
protolengua
un grupo de idiomas relacionados así se
llama familia de lenguas que tiene
varias ramas y su familias
pero primero Cómo sabemos Qué idioma se
relacionan los sonidos parecidos no
indican mucho podrían ser falsos
cognados o simples préstamos en vez de
tener una raíz común
la gramática y la sintaxis son más
fiables así como el vocabulario básico
tal como pronombres números o
parentescos donde hay menos
probabilidades de préstamo comparando
estos rasgos y buscando patrones
habituales de cambios de sonido y
correspondencias entre estos idiomas los
lingüistas establecen relaciones y
rastrean pasos concretos en su evolución
e incluso reconstruyen idiomas
anteriores sin documentos escritos la
lingüística puede incluso revelar pistas
históricas importantes tales como el
origen geográfico y el estilo de vida de
pueblos antiguos basándose en qué
palabras son suyas y cuáles son
préstamos
los lingüistas tienen dos problemas al
reconstruir el árbol de los idiomas
uno es que no se sabe con certeza donde
terminan las ramas es decir que
dialectos se consideran idiomas
separados y viceversa el chino se
clasifica como un solo idioma pero sus
dialectos son ininteligibles entre sí
mientras que el español y el portugués
pueden entenderse mutuamente los idiomas
hablados hoy en día no están en
categorías claramente separadas sino que
su transición es gradual cruzando
límites y clasificaciones la diferencia
entre idioma y dialecto es a menudo una
cuestión política y nacional en vez de
ser un rasgo lingüístico por eso la
respuesta a Cuántos idiomas hay puede
ser entre 3000 y 8.000 dependiendo de
quién cuenta además Cuanto más atrás nos
remitamos en el tiempo hacia lo alto del
árbol hay menos pruebas de las lenguas
allí la principal división de familias
de lenguas representa el límite en que
se puede establecer las relaciones con
una certeza razonable por lo que
supuestamente de los idiomas de
diferentes familias no se relacionan a
ningún nivel pero Esto puede cambiar
aunque las relaciones a un nivel más
alto o súper familias son especulativas
unas han sido aceptadas y otras están
siendo consideradas sobre todo con
idiomas de población nativa reducida que
aún no han sido estudiadas ampliamente
puede que nunca descubramos Cómo
surgieron los idiomas o si todos tienen
un antepasado común dispersado por la
torre de Babel de las migraciones cuando
oigas un idioma extranjero pon atención
podría no ser tan extranjero como
piensas
los estudiantes de todo el mundo están
desarrollando sus ideas en charlas
estilo Ted con los materiales de las
charlas para estudiantes de Ted maestros
pueden descargar este plan de estudios
gratuito en punto
ted.com/es español/ materiales